attendez
[Musique]
il ya quelque chose en vo qui plaît v
comme veronica qu'est ce que vous faites
ici
v comme victoria il ne sait pas nous
sommes jumelles mais s'il a touché un
seul des cheveux des renégats je veux
pas d'histoires rien comme moi avec le
fils du propriétaire jim et doit être
opéré
la solution est de l'emmener à
l'étranger je dois sortir jam et du
mozambique
on laisse trouver l'argent pour ça cinq
cent mille euros vous semble-t-il
suffisant pour résoudre vos problèmes
ce type sans scrupule à abuser de la
naïveté coiffeur vie comme la vengeance
de veronica lundi mardi jeudi vendredi à
11h40 sur la première